here with reaction California
Congressman Devin Nunez Oh
congressman una that looks like a John
Deere behind him hmm tractor some one of
the great American companies we have he
comes from a family of three generations
of farmers and still farms today along
with California farmer Matthew Leiter is
with us good to see you
Matthew I will defer to you now I don't
know I'm not a farmer but I have a deep
respect for the science behind farming
the the chemical composition of the soil
what you do in drought years when you
have certain diseases that pop up
creating stronger more vibrant products
for the American people I would think
it's a little more complicated than the
way Mayor Bloomberg or farmer Mike
described it would you like to educate
him oh absolutely Sean if mr. Bloomberg
would like to come to Tulare County be
happy to lend him a pair of my boots and
he could follow me around for three days
and show them just how much science and
government relations and government
going through the regulations on how
just an everyday turn on the water
irrigate our crops do pest and disease
prevention I mean it's it and what do
you think about their entire group of
people with way smarter Matt what do you
front citrus in almonds what an almond
citrus anonymous awesome because you
know what food oranges and lemons yeah
Wow let me tell you I've never had a
better orange in my life though when I
lived in California picked it right off
a tree for a kid from New York that was
a pretty cool story United States yeah
congressman Nunez I did not know that
your family was involved in the farming
industry for all these years tell us
about your background with this well
thank you Sean if you remember about ten
years ago you came out here to the
valley to look at the irrigation systems
this is the San Joaquin Valley we're the
breadbasket of the solar system we like
to say 300 different crops grow here and
it takes a hell of a lot of experience
to do it generations of farmers it's
very scientific as you said Mike
Bloomberg seems to think that this is
just like you know buying a chip
at Walmart and printing some water on it
that's not how this works it is it is
quite complicated and it's not just the
farmers it's it's it's getting that food
safely all the way to a grocery store in
Manhattan so that it doesn't poison
someone so there's a lot that goes into
it and look I this is really on the
crazy meter as you just said if Donald
Trump would have said anything like this
he would be hounded at nauseam until he
retracted the crazy statement and and
you probably won't see anybody approach
him at the debate tomorrow night about
his crazy statements well can I ask you
all right so we haven't taken multiple
shots against minorities and women and
farmers needing more gray matter we're
about to report some breaking news about
comments he's made in the past about
gays lesbians transit that gender
individuals is under fire for referring
to transgender women as some guy wearing
a dress using it it as a pronoun I don't
know how's that gonna go over with the
Democratic base Devon well look they're
in disarray right now I think they were
in in denial that socialist Bernie had a
chance to win the nomination and what's
happened here is is it and I've said
this before they're the party they're
like the dog that caught the car so
they've been letting this socialism you
know leech out all over the country in
our big city so much so they've poisoned
their own their own voting base to where
now Bernie Sanders the poll just came
out just hours ago is doubling up his
nearest opponent here in California he's
winning Nevada so look I think it's
highly likely Bernie is their nominee
that's why they're now the Democrats and
the in the establishment the Democratic
Party they're pleading for Bloomberg
just spend more of your millions we got
to stop Bernie that's what's happened
immediately so the president I believe
congressman Nunez rightly so is
frustrated and now speaking out we have
all this evidence premeditated fraud
FISA Court using Hillary's bought and
paid for dirty dossier with funnel money
to a law firm could be a campaign
finance issue she never got intro
for the espionage act and having
classified information on a server nor
did she get in trouble for subpoenaed
emails that she deleted and acid-wash
will plead spit and then of course the
whammer's with the devices and of course
not only premeditated fraud but they
spied on a presidential candidate a
transition team deep into a presidency
now I understand there's also the
outsourcing of spying abroad to Allied
intelligence agencies to circumvent
American laws president I think has a
right to be frustrated because it seems
like and I'm not I believe the Attorney
General is doing his job I really
believe it I think he's getting to the
bottom of it I think it's a hard day but
I understand the president's frustration
also yeah the president is actually
Shaun is gonna be here tomorrow he's
gonna be out in the San Joaquin Valley
tomorrow and I'm gonna have a chance to
talk to him I'm sure we this will come
up on you know what is the FISA Court
going to look like in the future that's
something that's that's got to be fixed
this two-tiered justice system that we
have in this country is totally
unacceptable but but back to the to the
topic you were talking about irrigation
technology you were out here 10 years
ago
Delta's Reza United States campaigning
came out here to the valley valley two
times and he understands that that that
water is the key to life he understands
these projects are very important so
he's going to be coming out tomorrow to
announce you know even in California
he's going to come out here and announce
that he's gonna open up more water for
farmers that Mike Bloomberg may not
understand we actually need water to
farm here in this room good old farmer
Mike congressman thank you
Matt thank you and thank you to all the
farmers that feed the entire country
that works so hard under difficult
conditions mastering the science of
Agriculture at such a sophisticated
level the only people that seem to need
gray matter the people that have no clue
where their food comes from thank you
for all you do every day